alors là ça va être un débat animé
encore si vous nous rejoignez bien sûr
ses balances ton post on est en direct
il est minuit 9 et soizic perrot
adjointe à la mairie de pontivy et
professeur à loudéac nous a rejoint
merci merci matin à nos gars est au
coeur du mammouth au titanic la
déséducation nationale est avec nous
merci aussi merci d'être là et gérant
blog en serre proviseur et auteur de la
vérité sur votre école alors on va
débattre de tout ça pour ou contre les
policiers dans les lycées alors un élève
a donc menacé son professeur avec une
arme en lui demandant de l'inscrire
présents ou absents
la scène s'est déroulée au lycée edouard
branly à créteil c'est une vidéo qui
date de jeudi dernier qui le montrent en
train de faire voilà ce geste il a été
mis en examen dimanche pour violences
aggravées et plus précisément pour
violences ayant entraîné une cape une
incapacité temporaire de travail de huit
jours
alors il s'agit de violences aggravées
pour plusieurs raisons usage d'une arme
même si c'était même si elle était
factice c'est un enseignant qui a été
visé et la scène s'est déroulée dans un
établissement scolaire lhps on a la
vidéo de l'élève que vous avez peut-être
dû voir regarder
[Rires]
alors on a d'ailleurs appris quelques
informations à propos de ce que lille le
lycéen a dit devant les enquêteurs il a
reconnu les faits mais n'a pas semblé
prendre conscience de leur gravité
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il en a pris
conscience parce que je vous dis oui on
l'a eu au téléphone et il était très
très mal voilà où nous en tout cas voilà
il était il et voilà ils accusent le
coup et laisser c'est normal mais là je
pense que là il a pris conscience de la
gravité des choses si la braquer c'est
parce qu'il n'habitait il n'admettait
pas que l'enseignante l' inscrits sur la
liste des absents malgré son retard en
classe il a d'ailleurs révélé qu'il ne
savait pas que la scène était filmée
l'adolescent a depuis été remis en
liberté il doit respecter des mesures
provisoires en attendant une nouvelle
comparution devant un juge pour enfants
il aura 16 ans le mois prochain il
risque 40 mois de prison maximum
malgré tout le lycéen bien évidemment
quelques règles à respecter un bien sûr
interdiction de rentrer en contact avec
son enseignante il ne peut plus
séjourner dans le val-de-marne et doit
poursuivre sa scolarité il en a
maintenant subir une enquête
deux personnalités alors d'autres
personnes ont aussi été impliqués
vendredi dernier il ya également eu une
autre personne qui a été relâché il
s'agit de la personne qui a introduit le
faux revolver dans le lycée et les
policiers sont toujours à la recherche
de l'auteur de la vidéo alors ce matin
on l'a vu donc notre nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur
christophe castaner appris à valady
voilà qu'il n'était pas possible qu'il y
ait des policiers maintenant dans les
lycées vous soizic perron des gestes que
vous êtes pour ou contre l'intervention
de la police dans les établissements
scolaires ce que vous pensez que ça peut
apporter quelque chose ou pas alors il
faut dire vous êtes adjoint à la mairie
de pontivy ont prouvé professeur à
loudéac et que vous avez déjà été
agressés vous allez nous raconter tout
ça dans un instant alors vous pensez que
ça va changer les choses ou pas moi je
suis contre pourquoi ci contre alors on
n'a pas parce que ça existe déjà
finalement on travaille déjà avec des
collectivités territoriales on travaille
déjà dans le cadre d'un clspd donc c'est
un contrat local de la prévention de la
délinquance
des fois par pure idéologie certains ne
met pas en place ce contrat local qu on
travaille avec les gendarmes la police
et tous les acteurs sociaux et éducatifs
sur un territoire
donc ça existe déjà on travaille déjà au
quotidien avec la gendarmerie dans nos
missiles sont des missiles sont sur
place à ce que possède ce sont des
mariages supplémentaires en dedans en
éducation nationale nous n'avons pas
besoin de moyens supplémentaires nous
avons juste besoin de courage
d'accord c'est quoi ça va être dissuasif
ou appliquons les peines à petits coups
n'ont pas les peines lapsus appliquons
l'échelle de sanctions tout simplement
il ya une échelle de sanctions qu'on
l'appliqué aujourd'hui on perd une
énergie folle dans des protocoles de
remédiation et on invente avec un
verbiage très savants finalement tout ce
qui ne permet pas d'appliquer l'échelle
de sanction dans un établissement
alors vous vous êtes déjà fait agresser
c'était en 2008 vous étiez profs
débutants que c'est ça en fait j'y
arrivais g
j'ai titularisé en 2003 j'ai passé
quatre ans au lycée pierre lescot dans
le coeur de paris dans le 1er
arrondissement vous des bords données ou
ça se passait très bien on avait un chef
d'établissement qui tenait le navire
était exigeant et en même temps ils
anticipaient toutes les difficultés je
n'ai jamais eu aucune difficulté après
les difficultés classiques d'un
professeur mais le proviseur était
toujours là pour soutenir ses
enseignants je suis arrivé à loudéac
dans un lycée que je connaissais bien
puisque c'était mon territoire
finalement et je suis arrivé un petit
peu effectivement assez à l'aise et au
bout d'un mois
au bout d'un mois dans ce lycée il y
avait des difficultés avec nombre de
collègues de l'équipe pédagogique
oui et puis le 13 octobre 2008 je me
souviens encore c'était il ya dix ans je
me suis fait agresser par une élève
qu'est ce qui s'est passé tout
simplement il y avait il y avait un
chahut dans la classe est effectivement
peut-être les erreurs de débutants j'ai
parlé de leur éducation et je leur ai
dit qu'est ce que c'est que cette
éducation et là la jeune femme m'a dit
m'a dit moi si mon père et se déplace
dans ma cocotte tu finis à l'aube faut
donc évidemment j'ai un peu perdu mon
sang froid je lui ai demandé de sortir
de la classe avec un élève le protocole
classique mais c'est finalement sont
venus la chercher ces pièces sont les
consignations peau des qualifications et
puis ils sont arrivés elle s'est
débattue elle m'a donné des coups de
pied je me souviens particulier la
semaine particulièrement choquant parce
que j'étais à l'hôpital j'ai quatre
jours d'interruption temporaire de
travail ou là et puis j'avais du mal à
en reparler oui c'est encore beaucoup
d'émotion parce que parce que c'est des
scènes difficiles et puis finalement je
les ai vécus tout au long de ça fait dix
ans que je suis dans cet établissement
on a eu des hauts et des bas il ya des
difficultés mais la violence giron série
du jour n'ont peu tous les jours et vous
redire penser souvent dès que la réponse
est en fait ce qui a été si violent
c'est pas il ya la violence physique de
l'élève mais la violence du système de
l'institution et du déni finalement qui
a passé à vous alors vous bernard
laporte vous êtes pour donc ce qu'a dit
christophe castaner ce matin pour les
policiers à un policier d'ailleurs par
par collège ou lycée
je suis pour c'est clair que ça ne
réglera pas les problèmes mais alors à
quoi ça déjà ça fait ça m'aidera un
petit peu de sécurité mais ça réglera
pas tous les problèmes
il ya une chaîne j'ai envie de dire la
première des choses c'est l'éducation
des parents ça c'est la première des
choses
donc moi je veux qu'on s'attaque au mal
c'est déjà là à l'éducation des enfants
s'il faut supprimer les allocations
situation il faut le faire parce que je
suis désolé un parent fait une maman ou
un papa il doit éduquer les enfants ça
c'est la première des choses
alors après encore une fois je le redis
mettre des policiers
çà et là par l'éducation dégâts mais ça
va faire peur à certains mais pas tout
le monde mais c'est en plus et ça va pas
porter de 2,2 de moins bien c'est une
certitude
ça va apporter un peu de sécurité mais
ça suffit pas chauffée que ça ça ne
suffit pas il personne là elle est
partout les policiers alors ils vont pas
on puisse aller dans les écoles déjà
qu'ils se fassent respecter dehors et
après on vous vend plus rien même pas
les six peut pas aller à l'école en
tueurs ont fait ployer mais pas déjà
allez c'est pas un sanctuaire l'école
alors vous agathe vous êtes contre pour
être un peu stupide tu dis que ça ne
peut pas être pire moi je pense au
contraire que le jeune qui peut insulter
sa professeur ou ses professeurs ses
enseignants le cadre de son éducation va
pas va pas se défiler devant un uniforme
au contraire moi je pense que ça peut
mettre en place des jeux de provocations
encore plus je vais paquita aide dans le
répressif je pense qu'il faille est
effectivement l'éducatif et et vous
disais je suis je suis désolé gb de
votre nom
il souhaite quelque chose de très
important le véritable problème et je
pense que ce qu'on ignore escompté trop
c'est cette omerta au sein du système
d'éducation nationale qui fait que les
violences scolaires le harcèlement
scolaire et tuent parce que tout
simplement les chefs d'établissement
pour monter dans leur carrière pour les
préfet ce que vous voulez pour pour
monter les échelons il faut que iain de
moins de conseil de discipline possible
par exemple moins d'élèves viré et c'est
donc il ya il ya une absence de soutien
total de la part des hiérarchies chez
les professeurs qui font qu'ils sont
complètement démunis qui sont dans un
dans un état où il ne peut même pas en
référé plus haut et son seul face à ce
qu'ils choisissent alors moi je veux pas
accabler les chefs d'établissement a
effectivement d'accord vous avez vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que vous étiez
d'avec la chef d'établissement qui
tenait la route oui notre ancien lycée
de la personne effectivement c'est la
géométrie du jeu mieux borie variable
autorités dans un établissement ses
soutiens dans cet établissement
oui mais l'institution aussi
l'institution tout en fait toute la
hiérarchie
finalement je vois nous en termes de
ressources humaines on est gérée
et avec un tableur excel c'est ce que
vous voulez c'est aujourd'hui le
rectorat c'est un tableau lens reims qui
qui gère huit plus de 800 mille
professeurs avec un tableau excel pour
vous dire si vous avez bien fait ou à la
dernière inspection que j'ai eu à l'été
j'ai peut-être en avoir une maintenant
mais c'était il ya 6 est en jeu mais
alors il même plus soizic vous dit vous
êtes fait donc fait agresser et sept
élèves donc le conseil de discipline a
décidé de garder d'élèves oui vous
l'avez recroiser donc avoué parce que ce
n'était pas de sa faute c'était
finalement la faute de la société parce
qu'elle était dans un milieu social
difficile
oui on vous l'avait regretté oui parce
qu'en fait finalement je vais reprendre
dans ma classe
ah oui et donc elle est restée droite
parce que finalement j'ai dû passer
outre la hiérarchie et puis je suis
intervenu autrement
et finalement elle a été renvoyée comme
cet élève à la fin de l'année avec un
rapport de trois un tas de rapports de 3
cm pour qu'elle s'est fait exclure en
mai de l'année suivante
eric naulleau vous êtes contre moi je
suis content parce que le fait même
d'introduire des policiers dans un
sanctuaire de l'éducation c'est
reconnaît qu'on a perdu sur qu'est ce
qu'on va faire un succès après ça va
être l'armée maintenant je pense qu'à
des armes à utiliser d'abord il faut que
toute la chaîne hiérarchique manifeste
son soutien au professeur d'abord en
finir avec cette règle absurde que ce
sont les v les professeurs les plus
jeunes qui sont envoyés dans les zones
les plus compliqués ça doit être un
verre ça doit être ça devrait des
professeurs beaucoup plus expérimentés
ensuite vous essayez de les défendre les
chefs d'établissement m'enfin dans le
mouvement pas de vagues et des tas de
dénonciation de chefs d'établissement
qui disent non c'est pas bon pour notre
établissement 10 à gaza sous le tapis
ensuite je trouve que ça devrait aller
plus haut mais je trouve que cette
professeur qui s'est fait braquer elle
mérite pour ce qui lui est arrivé pour
son comportement une photo avec le
président de la république
elle le mérite plus qu'un délinquant la
torse nu qui sous les doigts d'honneur
un appareil photo à autre chose je
trouve qu'elles le méritent plus il y
aurait dû avoir un soutien beaucoup plus
personnel et puis moi ça s'émeut le
volet un peu éducatif un peu préventif
mais sur le volet répressif
je trouve que les fauteurs de troubles
quand quelqu'un en vient à brandir une
arme et a braqué un prof
je trouve que ces fauteurs de trouble
devraient être exclues du système est
versé dans un système parallèle cela
vous allez les exclure complètement vous
allez rigoler
c'est annie vont revenir mais pendant un
moment par oseo les sortir de ce système
les mettre dans des centres d'éducation
fermé avec méthode et jaras que les
méthodes traditionnelles ne marche pas
et vont regarder ce qui se passe
il braque et il y en a un qui filme en
rigolant donc mais le mauvais exemple se
répand tout de suite et l'autre qui
passe dans le champ en faisant des
doigts d'honneur
ces types là sont des brebis galeuses je
dis pas qu'il faut les exclure avis mais
je dis que pendant un moment il faut les
sortir du système il faut arrêter cet
angélisme
il faut protéger les professeurs
protéger notre système et protéger ces
gamins-là contre eux mêmes et cette
semaine on a eu des nouvelles donc de
cette professeure puisqu'il y avait son
avocate qui était sur l'antenne d'europe
1 regardez professeurs étaient donc
devant son ordinateur concentré
puisqu'elle est habité un compte rendu
elle n'a pas vu arriver ces jeunes ce
qu'elle a vu après c'est comme une arme
une arme pointée quelques centimètres
son village elle ne s'est pas à ce
moment là c'était une arme factice ou
pas et donc elle s'est comportée de
manière à mon sens exemplaire elle a
gardé son calme pour ne pas envenimer
faut pas oublier que il ya des élèves
qui sont à proximité que ça aurait pu
dégénérer elle ne savait pas elle a opté
pour une attitude justement parce que en
fait la plus appropriée
alors pourquoi on entend ça parce qu'il
ya plein de gens qui ont dit mais on
avait l'impression qu'il rigolait avec
avec l'élève que c'était plutôt bon
enfant donc c'est pour ça il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont critiqué son attitude
donc c'est pour ça que son avocate a
répondu sur l'antenne d'europe 1
là-dessus qu'elle a dit voilà c'était
l'attitude qu'elle a choisi d'adopter
alors si vous nous rejoignez soit dick
peyron est avec nous c'est une
professeur donc adjointe à la mairie de
pontivy et professeur à loudéac
vous avez été agressé par une élève
idatsa disons nous avait raconté il ya
un instant c'était en 2008 à côté de
vous il ya une autre personne qui nous a
rejoint fin qui avait clos depuis le
début c'est anne-sophie nogaret hauteur
du mammouth au titanic la déséducation
nationale et vous aussi vous vous êtes
fait agresser vous êtes donc vous étiez
donc professeur vous avez arrêté du
professeur maintenant qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé alors je précise
il s'agit d'une agression mais qui
verbal donc s'est pas séparé il s'est
passé que c'était un élève qui s'était
déjà fait repérer très vite quelques
jours après la rentrée en me disant
nique ta mère parce que je vais demander
son carnet de correspondance bon ok je
crois qu'il avait été exclu une journée
j'avais exigé qu'il s'excuse il avait eu
beaucoup de mal bon il avait fini par le
faire et
quelques pas de trois semaines plus tard
je fais pour habitude que mes élèves se
débarrassent de leur chewing gum ils
n'ont pas de chewing gum en cours voilà
donc si on a tous entendu ça ainsi les
rues minos et pas ici sinon la larry et
donc qui me dit que non il a pas de
chewing gum donc ce qui bon ça va enfin
si voilà je sais donc ça va on arrête
maintenant 1 et est en fait il là il m'a
traitée de [ __ ] et donc je lui dis de
sortir il a refusé de se recueillir en
me disant ah là là tu fais ta malines
maintenant qu'est ce que tu vas faire
nananana bon j'en vois un élève chercher
le proviseur et sentant que le proviseur
allait venir en fait il m'a il a si des
sorties en me disant qu'il allait me
casser la gueule comme ça je vais
vraiment me malines et c'est donc ça
c'est une chose mais l'agression à la
limite je la situe plus du côté de
l'institution que de sept élèves
finalement bon qui était voilà et parce
que le proviseur tout de suite après m'a
dit non
c'est de votre faute entre 1,8 et bien
parce que je l'avais provoquer parce que
ça se trouve il avait pas de chewing gum
et que du coup je l'avais baptisé je
sentais que ce taux oui c'est que vous
avez le proviseur paul à la suite de ça
que vous avez décidé d'arrêter ben c'est
pire il ya eu pire encore j'ai fini par
obtenir un truc qui ressemble pas grand
chose mais qui s'appelle une commission
éducative parce que le poseur m'avait
dit vous ne réclamez rien du tout c'est
à vous de vous adapter à cette élève là
c'est d'ailleurs très bizarre que vous
avez des yéyés déjà eu des problèmes
avec lui une fois d'accord et il ya une
commission éducative ou en fait j'ai
sauvé sur éducatif pour laisser la
première on va dire c'est la première
sanction qui est exercée en fait ça sert
à rien on réunit l'équipe pédagogique le
donc les profs l'élève
voilà ses parents aurait dit c'est pas
bien surtout un tard est maintenant tu
es pisino gare à toi voilà bon en gros
ça n'a rien du tout mais ça se fait et
genre vous habitez bourse a du bon
surtout c'est qu'il a été dit juste
dispensé de mon cours cet élève la
aouichette haut on l'a dispensé de mon
cours et les parties on l'a raccompagné
chez lui il est malheureusement des
profs aux élèves profs de quoi les abbés
développement des profs pas
applaudissements mais vraiment on est
tous avec toi
on sait que tu es à saisir ta chance et
donc il y avait peu de philo il avait
avec une collègue que j'ai beaucoup
plainte mais en fait moi j'ai après j'y
suis plus je suis d'açaï d'etterbeek et
les autres professions qui vous ont pas
soutenu a pas du tout a vraiment au jour
où il y avait aucun problème est
vraiment le problème pouvait venir que
de moi il y avait que c'était un élève
vraiment alors certes il n'est jamais en
cours certes il avait passé à faire et
vous avez pas son boulot mais finalement
ils étaient tous comme ça mais non
niveau discipline vraiment quand il
était là c'était super et maintenant et
c'est un élève très gentil le problème
pouvait venir que c'est pas vrai donc le
problème vous écoute vous oui bien sûr
j'étais raciste l'élève était noir là
s'est construit j'étais raciste
voilà alors ça m'a pas été dit comme ça
en face mais c'est je sais que c'est ce
qui s'est dit après ce qui a fait que
vous avez vous avez arrêté
ah oui enfin j'y suis retourné après
parce que mes élèves me réclamer en fait
j'avais des abats de lancer élèves il
n'y a que des mauvais professeurs
cette phrase émane lille là elle est
vraie phrase est complètement les bains
je fais un mauvais professeurs la non
mais on peut dire ça comme ça au hasard
au détour si vous avez dit quelque chose
à faire ok j'ai entendu parler de
quelque chose qui m'a interloqué
c'est l'enfance et l'enfance et l'enfant
non si le professeur c'est le professeur
c'est le professeur et le braqueur là tu
penses que c'est que l'enfant et c'est à
nous de faire quelque chose moi je sais
pas oui on va le sauver
les 1800 l'élève fc je n'avais pas
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un âne
sophie o'gara était à la sculpture c'est
que la police comme l'a dit notre
ministre de l'intérieur ce matin ce
qu'on pensait que mettre des policiers
dans les collèges ou les lycées ça va
changer que non je pense qu'il faut
sanctuariser l'école je pense qu'il faut
la débarrasser de ces délinquants parce
que si la police vient dans l'école ça
descend que tu as he is l'école est par
contre il faut que l'école ça sanctuary
zay il faut plutôt que on vire en fait
ceux qui enfreignent la loi enfin c'est
moi ça me semble de l'ordre de
l'évidence
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes toujours
dans l'éducation nationale n'est plus
professeur vous fait quoi maintenant je
travaille
dans un rectorat d'accord vous êtes
mieux j'ai pas encore commencé adacore
très bien mais c'est la course que je
serais pour la pression est devenue
insoutenable
non c'est un truc d'humiliation serge
supporte pas d'être humilié et je ne
supporte pas qu'on me marche dessus et
je ne peux pas retourner voir un élève
dans les couloirs qui m'a traitée de
[ __ ] et qu'on a un caractère un peu
d'un rappeur dit voilà alors donc j'ai
l'impression que vous en voulez plus à
vos collègues
les garçons proviseur au système cas
l'élève will élèves
enfin oui bien c'est ça c'est ça vous a
dégoûté du système complètement ceci ce
n'est qu'une accumulation fasr que ça ça
m'est arrivé c'est pas la première chose
c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
que je sois que j'ai observé qui me
concernait pas mais que j'ai observé des
profs par exemple qui se faisait
insulter et qui devait s'excuser auprès
de l'élève devant le proviseur moi c'est
un grand classique
c'est une honte c'est pas ce n'est pas
tous des enfants du proviseur c'est vrai
que là alors choisi que vous n'êtes pas
encore été dégoûté ce que vous avez déjà
eu envie de tout plaquer parce qu'on l'a
dit si vous nous rejoignez elle a été
agressée
soizic oui ça m'est arrivé très souvent
mais j'ai la chance oui j'ai la chance
d'avoir un engagement politique
finalement et puis je me suis épanoui
aussi dans cet engagement et j'ai gardé
quand même cet équilibre avec un temps
partiel dans dans l'éducation et
l'engagement politique et qui me donne
la force de cet engagement alors soizic
est ce que vous vous êtes soutenu est ce
que vous vous avez été soutenu par les
autres professeurs par le proviseur pas
parler de les autres collègues nous on a
la chance d'être en lycée professionnel
j'ai une anecdote à raconter c'est l'an
dernier j'avais un proviseur que je ne
voyais pas beaucoup puisque l'année
dernière j'étais à quart temps avec mes
des charges d'accord électoral
je précise que j'ai été payé à 40 ans y
est vous avez d'abord va pas vérifié non
non non je préfère le préciser parce
qu'aujourd'hui politique est toujours
décriée par rapport à ses indemnités jeu
juste jolie et c'était en début d'année
je lis un e-mail d'une autre collègue
qui racontait une scène catastrophique
dans sa classe et où il y avait vraiment
faits graves de raconter dans cette
histoire est donc j'interpelle le
lendemain matin le proviseur je
l'appelle au téléphone et j'étais dans
une salle d'un bout de couloir et je lui
dis monsieur j'espère que vous allez
réagir par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
dans cette classe ultime et madame vous
savez je sais ce que c'est qu'un lycée
professionnel j'ai mon épouse qui est
professeur de lycée professionnel j mais
monsieur au bout du couloir
vous avez un lycée professionnel amnésie
venez nous voir en fait le proviseur
était quasiment pas là parce qu'on a eu
des soucis parce qu'il était attachant
et de corsier donc donc ça tient
beaucoup à ce qu'on vend d'antan c'est
que ça tient beaucoup au proviseur voilà
et ovales acquis et c'est ce que vous
dites quand vous avez un très bon
proviseur avant ça se passait bien et là
ça se fasse pas le karim zéribi vous
êtes contre la police à l'école oui mais
moi ce qui me surprend et qui ce qui me
désole c'est que franchement on a
l'impression à travers un fait divers de
découvrir la situation alors que ça fait
des années que les profs vivre l'enfer
qui sont insultés cas de l'irrespect qui
sont agressés qui a de l'impunité qu'il
n'ya pas cette cohésion nécessaire avec
certains parents or la première des
choses avant de parler de la police
c'est la restauration de l'autorité du
maître et des parents si ces derniers
n'exercent pas leurs prérogatives ou ne
peuvent les exercer pour les maîtres et
les enseignants je pense qu'ils ne
peuvent pas les conditions ne sont pas
réunies on leur demande de ne pas faire
de vagues
d'ailleurs le hashtag c'est pas un
fantasme adrien exactement il s'est
rempli si on ne regarde pas la réalité
en tant qu on les donne la parole au
professeur comment vous voulez combattre
le phénomène si vous ne regardez pas la
réalité un patio vous dit on met tout
sur le tapis on ne fait pas de vagues
parce que derrière c'est peut-être des
primes collège juin mais la réalité
c'est que encore une fois on va pas
faire de nostalgie mais aujourd'hui le
maître a du mal à restaurer l'autorité
il n'est pas soutenu par son institution
il n'est pas assez soutenue par les
parents qui parfois se ligne contre lui
quand vous avez combien de cas on a vu
des gamins qui sont sanctionnés par
leurs enseignants le père qu'est ce
qu'il fait ou la mer nous à notre époque
on recevait un coup de pied dans les
fesses et on nous disait l'enseignante a
sanctionné moi je te re sanctionne et on
n'avait pas envie de déraper aujourd'hui
il vient de frapper l'un seniors vous
croyez que c'est acceptable ça tant que
la société se voit alors à la face et
acceptera ce type de comportement on
nous
pourra pas prendre le dessus sur un ado
qui se croient tout permis et dalle est
d'ailleurs j'ajoute que si je suis
contre la police dans les collèges dans
les lycées c'est parce que je la veux
dehors déjà je l'avais aux abords déjà
quand elle n'est pas dans le quartier du
gamin et quand c'est la loi du caïdat
qui montent trop gamin l'exemplarité de
l'autorité mais il reproduit à
l'intérieur de l'école se qaïda il
refait ce qu'ils voient dans son carré
il nous faut près pour faux et la police
nationale un professeur mireille sery
jean métay de bruit qu'elle arrive et
vous vous leviez vous bien sûr déjà il y
avait une demi heure de conte moi c'est
[Applaudissements]
siri dernier avait pas d'école oui ça
existe
j'ai fait des heures de colle t rim
syrie a fait des heures d'école corrie
pourquoi j'ai énormément mais j'étais
chez les bonnes soeurs mois ah oui ah
oui oui j'avais
c'est très bonne élève très bon et si je
le savais pas mais vous êtes
irrespectueux j'étais obligé away
c'était comme ça devant tu voyais le
prof c'était comme si tu étais le grand
de la cité et sister way à et maintenant
ça passe et plus le nommer cyril jeux
paraissent intéressants et qui dit doc
est sûr c'est intéressant mais c'est une
autre époque et il faut effectivement à
niamey dans la gueule là il faut voter
et non et c'est moi c'est mon ami c'est
mon frère ne qu'il faut restaurer
effectuant ses codes qui sonne des codes
et je dirais d'autorité pas d'
autoritarisme hong kong sont aujourd'hui
on a une pression cautionnons
autoritaire a le petit l'enfant roi
il faut qu'on arrête avec ça mais je
vais vous dire l'échelle des sanctions
l'échelle de la sanction il y avait une
surveillante ce qui m'expliquait ac
lorsque vous aviez un gamin qui étaient
exclus d'un collège ou d'un lycée
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait d'après vous on
le met dans un autre collège et au lycée
et qu'est-ce qu'on accueille à la place
un enfant exclu d'un autre collège au
lycée
donc on permute les exclus à très
fraîche main on marche sur la tête
moi je suis pour qu'on crée j'ai pas
peur de le dire des maisons de
redressement pour des enfants
délinquants et qui écrit doivent
réapprendre les règles si les parents ne
sont pas capables avec à 15 1 avec déjà
12 10 choisit alors non on a des centres
d'éducation renforcés soisy à nice ils
sont largement insuffisants renseigne
sur le nombre de places est disponible
ça ne suffit pas ré déjà soigné qu'elle
est allée au bout du rouleau donc au ce
qu'avait choisie car on sait qu'avec
jeudi alors on a on agir au blog est
avec nous vous êtes vous étiez ancien
proviseur
voilà et vous dites que votre après vous
êtes à la retraite après 40 ans dans
l'éducation nationale et vous portez un
regard très très négatif sur le système
éducatif vous dites c'est un système
valable dans les années 50 mais
aujourd'hui c'est obsolète
alors moi ce que je pensais que le
système qui existait qui avait sans
doute des performances est à peu près 60
ans
ce système a grossi énormément est
devenu absolument obèses et que en fait
il ne fonctionne plus bien le problème
que vous soulevez sur la violence
éventuelle présence de la police dans
les établissements ce n'est qu'un des
domaines dans lequel l'éducation
nationale échoue parce qu'en fait
l'éducation nationale n'est pas capable
de réaliser ce qu'il dit personne ne vit
à personne
chacun
reste dans sa petite dans son petit
fonctionnement le hashtag la madrague
hashtags été mise en place
certaines réalités il ya effectivement
un certain nombre de chefs
d'établissement ceux qui souhaitent ne
pas multiplier les processus
disciplinaire parce qu'en fait ça va
plus ou moins est mal vu par leur
hiérarchie
alors justement cote quand quand les
professeurs disent voilà le proviseur
c'est lui qui donne la ligne de conduite
et de proviseur ci va avoir des bonus il
va être bien vu au rectorat n'y a pas de
bonus et ses avoirs proviseur qui a un
établissement dans lequel il ya toujours
des problèmes
il faut forcément qui rendre des comptes
bon il faut qu'ils expliquent pourquoi
radio télé de relais mais donc
éventuellement si jamais on considère
que c'est de ces explications sont un
peu faibles
les gens qui sont dans les inspections
académiques au rectorat sont pas
complètement clio ils savent très bien
qu'il ya des endroits qui sont plus
difficiles que l'eau assure d'ailleurs
qu'il peut y avoir des circonstances qui
ont entraîné un certain nombre
d'incidents mais la façon de réagir et
d'être capable de gérer ces choses là si
jamais on est capable de les taire
complètement et bien en est qu en
définitive on n'a plus à se justifier
giron blog est ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre vous la police dans les
établissements mais je pense que c'est
un mois je suis pour la police chaque
fois qu'elle est utile je pense que
c'est un d'une certaine façon est un
faux débat dire que en fait le problème
c'est pas de mettre plein de policiers
dans les écoles mais oui mais quand on a
besoin de flics
il faut pouvoir les amener dans les
écoles si jamais il ya une situation de
tension
si il ya un certain nombre d'élèves qui
sont particulièrement menaçants ça peut
aussi être le cas parce que ça j'ai
connu cette situation quand il ya des
bandes qui viennent s'affronter régler
leurs comptes les unes contre les autres
dans les établissements où quelqu'un ça
peut être méchant dit l'argent africain
vous dire moi je reçois un sms de
quelqu'un qui est surveillant là il me
dit on nous demande dans les collèges
rep de fausser les taux d'absence et de
faire disparaître les rapports
d'incidents et pour cause de bagarre ou
insulte avec des profs pour toucher plus
de
prime non venez on va revenir là dessus
que je n'exerce plus j'ai été dans des
établissements réputés difficiles comme
par exemple à villiers le bel
j'ai appelé dans des établissements
beaucoup plus cool en quelque sorte pris
mon papa de mes primes
bon alors alors attendez pas ce qu'on va
revenir à dieu dans le prix moyen des
deux milieux de jérôme parce que je dois
je dois lancer la plus dans un instant
mais soit dit qu'ils avaient l'air de
dire oui et donc votre la halle à ce que
vous dites alors soizic oui en fait le
chef d'établissement continue dans un
établissement difficile et ce qu'il a
envie c'est en partir le plus vite
possible de faire le moine vagues
possibles
effectivement ce qui existe qui revisite
un glissement dont le nombre d'élèves
justifierait qu'il soit classé en 2ème
ou 3ème catégorie puisque il ya un
système de médailles en fonction de
l'importance bacar dia dia il ya des
italiens qui saigne à blanc des zones
rep et qui sont surclassés circuit alors
au lieu alors qu'il doit dans deuxième
catégorie ils sont troisièmes à six mois
pour la police dans les écoles pourquoi
oui par exemple à nice c'est expérimenté
depuis six mois
ça marche bien mais pas que comme on l'a
dit il faut aussi l'éducation ce dont ne
parle pas suffisamment de mon point de
vue c'est que c'est pas que l'ado l'inde
où il a été plus jeune il a été un
enfant et lorsqu'on voit que dès la
maternelle les enfants tapent se
crachent dessus ne reste ne respecte pas
l'enseignant des laquais ce qui se passe
en amour deux choses de mon point de vue
d'abord des parents qui ont démissionné
et on revient l'éducation l'éducation
l'éducation l'éducation et là c'est très
important par exemple ce que fait par
exemple le ministre blanc caire sur
dédoublement à etc
on va pas deuxièmement il ya celle des
parents qui abandonnent mais il ya aussi
les parents qui on a parlé un peu trop
d'ailleurs de l'enfant moi c'est bip les
parents qui plombe mettre l'enfant à
l'école ils découvrent finalement que ce
n'est pas l'enfant rêver et rejette et
vous allez me contredire ou pas vous qui
est enseignante sur l'éducation
l'enfant finalement qui n'a aucune
relance non mais j'ai dit pour ovins
pour mais pourquoi absolument pour ben
parce que justement ce que ça va changer
les choses
moi je pense que ça va aider à changer
les choses moi je suis comme a dit
monsieur je suis pour la police partout
où elle peut être utile mais attention
pas que alors les du cac
si on si vous êtes pour rôtir à mousse
moi je suis pour et même j'aimerais
aller encore plus loin puisque moi y'a
un truc que j'ai beaucoup regretté
c'est par exemple quelque chose qui
permettait à beaucoup de gens de creuser
à la racine et de d'apprendre le un
petit le respect des autres le respect
de la hiérarchie c'est le service
militaire mois pour moi c'est un grand
regret que le service militaire n'existe
plus dans ce pays puisque ça permettait
à pas mal de jeunes
oui mais j'étais fâché après l'école
donc là restons sur le sujet ramos pour
vous êtes pour pourquoi pour peau parce
que moi je pense que là comme l'a dit
notre cher monsieur là où la police a
besoin d'être il faut qu'elle soit là
une chose de graphique il ya beaucoup de
trafic de drogue qui se font aussi dans
les dents les dans les collèges dans les
lycées leur effet très lourd et même à
l'intérieur du lycée ya beaucoup de
choses comme ça qui se font donc à
l'intérieur mettre quelqu'un qui
fouillent et qui met un petit peu plus
de deux ordres
mais quand il ya un délit quand il ya
une agression vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure la police a le droit de venir
dans ce mémoire à policiers dans sa
classe au lycée deux experts me disent
allez la caisse ou protestants or très
vite eu envie qu'il ya une question
qu'on se pose c'est la question des
moyens d'argent public
oui c'est ça on échoue on échoue à
l'éducation nationale et on remet des
policiers mais avec quel moyen sûr qu'on
ait s'alliant le t on à plus de 2200
milliards de dettes on leur met
effectivement un service ni un service
militaire mais des colonies de vacances
pour prenez l'expression et moi je dis
il dispose d solution toute simple on
remet des tiges ont fait des chantiers
tiges des champs comme ça existe déjà on
a des chantiers d'insertion sur notre
territoire qui te font avec des
associations
ça fonctionne très très bien donc j'ai
mis en place dans la ville des chantiers
d'argent de poche pour les jeunes ça
fonctionne très bien qu'on donne des
moyens aux collectivités juridique qu'on
donne des moyens financiers aux
collectivités mairies départements
régions n'y a pas d'amour mettre en
place des tiges et qu'on applique
l'échelle de sanctions dans l'école
c'est aussi simple que ça arrête on
ajouté de moyens on n'a pas besoin de
moyens parce que le courage c'est vrai
que c'est vrai ça va être très compliqué
des médecins policiers par goal fg
rallye c'est insensé des mois garam des
lourds comme que cyril on a un problème
aux urgences de l'hôpital public va
devoir s'en remettre un policier mais on
a un problème et il va falloir mettre un
policier pas possible c'est une escalade
etc
bernard saidal édition il ya des
problèmes ils n'ont pas mettre partout
quand même à certains moments je pense
quand même que les professeurs ils
doivent se sentir en sécurité
on a dit ça réglera pas tout mais sa pop
ça peut apporter que du lien c'est que
l'éducation nationale
on est là pour éduquer oui lesquelles je
vois comme vous note surtout il faut
virer personnes non proviseur qui dînent
assez gras celui-là les parties je suis
mais il est parti parce qu'ils mettaient
en danger les autres c'est toi qui doit
être bien noté
c'est pas rien et qui est le bordel
c'est la reine est tombé en fait on a là
aussi on marche sur la tête quoi on va
passer téléspectateurs les forces de
l'ordre dans les lycées pour à 43%
contre à 57% csars fait encore voilà ce
qui se passe sur ce plateau je veux dire
merci anne sophie nogaret du mahb où le
titanic éducation nationale et vos
témoignages des loisirs merci à jérôme
love d'avoir été avec nous et merci
soizic perron merci d'avoir été là
également et ne craquez pas d'accord
nous avons un sourire magnifique en plus
mais les cochons et je pense que les
élèves sont bien contents de vous avoir
on va se retrousser salue d'ailleurs
parce que j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler avec eux à voilà bah ça fait
plaisir
[Applaudissements]